all right carolina panthers looking for
a new quarterback one year after they
signed teddy bridgewater to a three-year
contract and they're going to take a 10
million cap charge if they move on from
teddy bridgewater but it seems like
they're ready to do it so the big
question for the panthers who will be
the quarterback in 2021 shireen let's do
it draft style i'll give you the first
pick because i'm in a semi-good mood
who is your selection right out of the
gates to be the starting quarterback for
the panthers week one
well i'ma leave the big name to you mike
because i don't think they're going to
get a big name to come in and if you
don't get somebody better than teddy
bridgewater right you have to keep teddy
bridgewater so i'm going to say they're
going to fail in their attempts to get a
better quarterback so they're going to
stick with teddy bridgewater and look to
redo this position in 2022.
that's very pragmatic and realistic but
it's no fun
it's very kind of you i mean ted
bridgewater eventually would have made
the list but
how how can i not go with deshaun watson
they're they're loading up the cannon
for the run at the sean watson espn told
us that last week three first round
picks and christian mccaffrey make it
happen so yeah deshawn watson
yeah and i don't think deshawn watson is
going to want to go there even though he
played at kemp clemson so that's kind of
my drawback my next pick mike i am going
to have fun with this i'm going to say
they're going to go with dak prescott
right no one gets traded
dak prescott becomes a free agent and he
goes to carolina how about that i knew
it i knew it i knew it my my two choices
for you for your next pick were dak
prescott first then roger staubach i
knew it so uh that's good that's good
and i like that i like that because if
they do the trade to dallas of russell
wilson right it's not like the cowboys
are gonna sign dak prescott to a 37.68
million dollar franchise tender and then
trade him he's walking away and they're
getting compensatory draft pick next
year so uh yeah that would be perfect
that would be
see that this is where the panthers now
have to
have to press pause on their effort to
go after deshaun watson and say wait a
minute wait a minute there's a chance
that dak prescott's going to walk right
through the door for us
if the cowboys bite on this on this
russell wilson hook all right next one
for me trevor lawrence if you fail to
get desean watson if dak prescott isn't
available you make the jaguars an offer
they can't refuse they drop down to
number eight you move up to number one
you make the argument hey look if the
bengals have done the deal with the
dolphins last year they could have had
justin herbert and all this other stuff
so why don't you do it urban meyer and
of course meyer is responsible why don't
you just keep all those picks and do it
yourself but i think a tepper david
tepper determined to get a franchise
quarterback and get a clemson guy if you
can't get the clemson guy who's proven
he can get it done go after the clemson
guy who's entering the draft
and i'll go i'll stick with that same
theme mike that they do draft their
quarterback this year and how about a
trade up for trey lance and i do think
they probably would have to trade up a
little bit to get him quarterbacks
always go earlier than we think they're
going to go right there's going to be a
run on quarterbacks and teams are going
to panic and they're going to move up
and say if we want the guy we're going
to have to get the guy so they may still
have to trade up a little bit to get
trey lance but i think trey lance is a a
real possibility for this team to draft
i uh
i i think a trade up to get zach wilson
is a possibility that'll be my last pick
because again i it's either deshawn
watson
or russell wilson or we can throw in dak
prescott if the dominoes fall that way
there isn't a clear
upgrade
franchise level guy in the nfl right now
beyond those three they're not going to
go after kirk cousins
i don't think
so
move up to get zach wilson and am i
misremembering this didn't teddy
bridgewater sign with the jets and then
get traded to the saints didn't he do
that that's right yeah so yeah so send
send teddy bridgewater back to the jets
so they can trade him to the saints
again or wherever else they want to
trade him all right uh i think we've
done as much damage as we can
with our completely made up guesswork at
who the panthers quarterback will be
let's move on to one in and one out give
me a name of someone that the panthers
will be adding other than obviously a
quarterback
well i don't have a williams on this i'm
gonna go with john feliciano they only
have one player on their offensive line
among their starting offensive line who
is signed
i do think they put the franchise tag on
taylor moton
at right tackle so they'll have him too
but they need to upgrade at the guard
position john miller and chris reed
their starting guards from last year are
free agents i'm going to go john
feliciano of the bills if the bills
can't resign him i think carolina is a
good landing spot for him
all right see i had put in the sheet
when i prepared for the show a franchise
quarterback so i i kind of put myself
into a box since we did that draft it's
my own fault for not being smarter about
you know the flow of the segment how
about john w smith the tight end from
the tennessee titans just throw a dart
there curtis samuel likely to walk away
in free agency they really haven't had a
potent tight end since greg olsen
um
you know so so since i've painted myself
into a corner i'll try to escape it by
desperately throwing out the name johnny
smith who's out for the carolina
panthers shireen
i think russell okong and i talked about
only having that one player under
contract well russell okong is a free
agent he's 32 injury history we know
that they resigned trent scott who
actually started three games at left
tackle last year
while russell was out with his injury so
i just think it's time for them to move
on they are ready to move on they'll
find an in-house candidate for the left
tackle spot mike
and you know the easy one is teddy
bridgewater out
if that is the way that it goes it seems
like they're ready to move on and i
think you get to a point where he's
going to want to move on that they could
end up with some other mid-level guy
if they completely alienate teddy
bridgewater the point where he wants out
so it's possible that he's not even
going to be available to them if he's
like i'm not going to continue to be
your quarterback when you're clearly
looking for someone else curtis samuel
one of their top receivers is another
possibility to leave he's a free agent
and you just have to ask how much money
do you invest in that position they've
got robbie anderson dj moore is going to
need to get paid at some point samuel
may be a luxury that they just can't
afford not many teams go three deep with
with receivers who are making a nice
chunk of change
um
so but uh look they got a lot to do and
they got high ambitions david tepper
wants to work the the game in his favor
and he has proven at least in the
business world he knows how to crack the
code he is trying desperately to crack
the nfl code sharing
yes he is mike and they want that that
quarterback to do it right sell out the
stadium trevor lawrence does make
perfect sense i just don't know if the
jaguars are going to be willing to trade
up there trade out i'm going back to
that club that clip
in all or nothing teppers in the back of
the suv the nfl set up to be eight and
eight and the way that you push it your
way great coach great gm great
quarterback great quarterback is this
year's objective
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports